enel campamento palestino de bourj al
chemali enel en libanés la vida de
grayssas alrededor de los lienzos
qué preguntar durante las patrullas en el
el cielo es
mínimo desde homebrews de la explosión
que derivó en un penneteau la noche de
stevia renace
[Música]
en gounod apariencia de tiempo que tienen
oxígeno por explicar la detonación volver
adivinen si estos pony segun contratos
fuentes militar este libanés tiene
sentado como en el tocino internacional de
tomó un depósito ubicado experto en demolición
y sus teselas movimiento
palestina hamas refugio explota mochila
pérol movimiento palestino social nacido
quesnel deposito local massena y corrio
tan caja de oxígeno a los destinos de su
paciente de escoville bourj al chemali
es una oda a discos como el
mentiroso de los regalos saciados de búsqueda
escena ayélé libanesa pronto nacional
no entre las facciones del cambio
para mantener el orden